foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best Oprah Winfrey
and my take on her top 50 rules for
success
joy and everybody has a different talent
and the reason we're all so messed up is
because you're looking at everybody
else's Talent yeah and wishing you had
some of their talent all the energy that
you spend thinking about wishing about
being jealous of envious of anybody else
is energy that you're not only putting
out it's going to come back to you
negatively but you're taking that away
from you all your energy should be
forced on what do I have to offer what
do I have to give how can I be used in
service because Dr King's message of not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined by service and there is not a
job in here that you can do that you
don't switch the Paradigm to service and
not make that job more fulfilling I
don't care what the job is if you say
I'm a singer I'm a dancer I'm an artist
I'm a teacher I'm a nurse I'm a doctor
I'm a janitor I'm a I'm a clerk I'm a if
you say if I look at this from how do I
use this in service to something bigger
than myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering to the world this is the beauty
of of my life there's not a thing that
happens to me that I don't look at it as
a
teaching learning experience and so
whenever I'm going into any kind of
crisis
I've said this many times before I'm
always looking for what is this here to
teach me and I would say reading is the
strongest
signal for success in the future that
I've ever seen it is the strongest
strongest strongest I got my first job
in radio when I was 16 years old because
I've been broadcasting since I was 16
years old but my first job I got because
I was a great reader when you are a
great reader you can articulate and
speak and command the English language
in ways that other people cannot and
people think you're a lot smarter than
you are lots of times because you're a
great reader have you ever met a person
who was a great reader when they were
young who was not successful you never
never it is the absolute best foundation
ever in life if I leave you with nothing
else it just know this for sure
there is not one
thing that has ever happened to you
not one experience not one encounter not
one crisis not one joyful thing that
hasn't happened just to make you better
and help you rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out that you are calling it in
when you actually start meditating or
praying or doing or having a spiritual
practice which is the number one thing
you need if you want to be successful in
the world you need something that gives
back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runeth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you because your cup is empty and
now they want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill your cup and make
yourself whole
that's your job also if you want to have
more self-confidence and self-belief the
sign says it can take up to
254 days of consecutive action for the
Habit the stick that's what I want for
you so design a custom free program
we're going to send you an unlisted
video for the next 254 days to shift
your confidence and belief forward
the lengthy join is in the description
below figure out
where your power base is your number one
job is to become more of yourself and to
grow yourself into the best of yourself
become so skilled so Vigilant so flat
out
fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed I think in
order to actually do the stuff money is
important but I also think the thing
that I hold the dearest and the reason
why uh the noise about running for
president moved me so uh humbly and
deeply is because it means that you have
somewhere in the work gain the people's
trust yes you have and there is nothing
more important to me than having the
trust of the people and the audience and
I I mean I recognize that it is the
audience who came every day and watched
you know from all over the world
yes that that helped me to be who I am
so I think the uh the the renowned the
the stand the standing the the ability
to be trusted and to say something but
also might listen don't play the
billionaire thing small don't play the
be small yeah it's it's a very big deal
because it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying gee I would like to
help so many people or you should go out
and help so many people you can actually
use that for yourself and I am now at
this stage of my career thinking about
how to do that more poignantly and
fruitfully I'm now looking for ways that
I can do that to uh create a level of
sustainability in within our communities
that will go long Beyond you know my
lifetime the first law is the third law
of motion in physics which says for
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in The Color Purple
When Miss Seeley says to Mr Everything
you even try to do to me is already done
to you
that is not just a rhetorical saying
that is law that is Newton's third law
of motion in physics which says
everything that goes out is coming back
it's just like everything that goes up
is coming down may take a long time to
come down is coming down everything that
goes out is coming back it's coming back
so to answer the power of manifestation
and meditation what meditation does is
sync you up with the source
what meditation does is allows you to
literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that
and so when you carry that out into the
world everything that you do comes from
the center of that alignment that's
coming from the source that we call God
we call Divine energy Divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it to we call life when you are
synced up with life
life just gives to you so when I first
started making money I was one of those
people who thought I gotta every time
somebody asked me yeah so go crazy you
go crazy you have to look within
yourself what do you want to do that's
that that means family members because
you get a lot of cousins
when you get the van Jones Show all of a
sudden you get good
so you decide for yourself and so I have
uh you know I've given away so much that
people don't know because most of the
time you don't hear about the people
that I've helped so people complain
about what I did or didn't do yeah I
don't know me don't know
you don't know me I do yeah I do and and
God does well I don't have any let me
let me get one more I have all of that
very much in check the reason why I was
number one for 25 years
is because I figured out early on there
is no story anybody has ever heard that
somebody else hasn't experienced
nothing
I also figured out
um probably maybe the first or second
year that all pain is the same
that a mother in Somalia feels the same
way as a weather in Seattle when she
loses her child
and the common denominator in The Human
Experience is our emotions and our
feelings and the more vulnerable and
open you are willing to be with your
story The more actual understanding you
create with other people and the more
powerful you become people don't think
less of you for sharing your story they
think more of you for having the courage
to share it what would you say to your
younger self oh honey honey
oh baby girl
what the world has in store for you
first of all would be relax it would be
stop being afraid and it would be
everything's going to be all right no
matter what you're going to be okay I
did this movie called their eyes are
watching God and I was an extra in and
it was a movie that Oprah was producing
and she had walked by and I was making
all the other extras laughing stuff I
was telling jokes and she she's like
you're a very funny young lady I was
like
yeah she's she was like what's your name
I said my name is Tiffany and I'm a
stand-up comedian and she said well keep
me up to keep me updated on your career
write me let me know what you got going
on I love comedy I said oh yeah I know I
know that it's a lot with writer right
right and I never got any nothing and I
think it's because it was a lot of
misspellings or something because you
know I wasn't a good reader at that time
so definitely not a good writer I see
but I'm better now well she she never
wrote back I wonder why let's ask her
why she didn't write back Oprah why
didn't you write back right back
[Applause]
thank you
so happy for you girl so this is a deal
oh
you are so so so good you are so so so
come on you told me that before in a
dream no
no it's true so it is my intention
my intention
to fulfill the dream of the creator
it is my intention to live to the
highest calling and be pressed to the
mark of the highest calling that I have
come to do and when you can ask the
Creator ask that which made you you what
is your dream for me I guarantee you
instead of you trying to define the
dream what is your dream for me if
you're able to
lean into the dream
that the Universe and all the forces of
of of of of light and love and power and
Grace by all the names that we call God
has for you nobody can touch you nobody
can touch you that show was on for 25
years in Chicago and uh when you did it
you won I think almost 50 Emmy Awards
and it was voted one of the best TV
shows in the history of TV so you ended
it though after 25 years to do other
things and we'll talk about that but no
regrets about ending that show no no we
got
whatsoever you know I I didn't want to
be punch drunk in the ring still trying
to uh come up with what is the next
thing what is the next thing because
over the years we became our own
greatest competition so when I first
started uh went National in 1986 every
time there would be another talk show oh
Geraldo Rivera oh what are we going to
do and then I realized a couple of years
in that you run your own race better
than anybody if you take the time to see
what everybody else is doing you lose
your ground and that I could be a better
me than I could be anybody else and so
no need of trying to compare myself to
other people one of the things I tried
to do all those years on the Oprah show
sometimes people were criticized me
because they felt that I didn't do
enough for race or racism but this is
what I always understood that for me my
role and my goal in life is to open this
open people's hearts that's what I do is
I I try to tell stories that allow
people to see themselves in the lives of
other people and for me it was always
more powerful and effective to do a show
for example on single parents raising
their children and just on the panel of
parents to have a black father
and to show the photographs or images of
that father putting his child to bed and
reading a story at night that to me is
more powerful than doing a story on
let's talk about uh fathers black
fathers who are raising their children
because the goal for me is to show that
we are all more alike than different and
that in in our Humanity in our ability
to express our humanness we are the same
so when you see a father putting his
child to bed at night and reading
stories and that man is black and you
know that's what your husband does and
that's what you do you you feel
everything you try to do is already done
so when I figured that out oh what I'm
putting out is what's coming back let me
get real clear about what it is I'm
putting out real clear so
I read a book about 1989 called seed of
the soul and in that book Gary zhukov
talked about the laws of karma of the
laws of cause and effect the third law
of motion and in that book he talked
about how intention your intention is
always one
with the law meaning before you even
think about a thing you have an
intention for the thing and that the
intention is going to determine the
outcome that's why the same people can
go to the same church service and
somebody walk down the aisle just to be
seen to put some money in the
church and somebody else who just goes
and just has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give the
intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when I figured
that out
I went whoa
I changed everything I did on my show I
called in the producers and I said from
this day forward I will no longer be
speaking to the KKK
I will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch from
this day forward I am only going to do
intentional television when you're
saying I know who I am and I'm telling
you it's the thread that runs through
everything it's the thing that allows
you to stand in your own truth and one
of the things for years at Maya Angelou
used to say to me is baby you need to
know that you alone are enough
you alone are enough when I started the
magazine they said you will not see a
prophet for at least the next five years
and we were profitable the first month
the second month and and and have been
since and so I thought oh okay those
predictions that is not really actual I
had no idea how difficult it would be
however I am really
um there's an old uh spiritual that says
wouldn't take nothing from a journey now
I really was speaking to step in this
morning he was saying it's a good thing
that you went through that because you
were living on the Mountaintop for the
past 25 years you created this machine
of the Oprah show that it just felt like
walking into okay here we go so no
Struggle No just it has become easy for
me to do so to be in a position to build
from scratch this network and to go
through everybody thinking it was going
to fail and there were days when I had
doubts myself like
I had to force myself to actually
practice what I had preached for years
about going inside staying with the
vision taking having every step move you
in the direction of the vision and
trusting trusting that building the
right team one of the things I started
to get
uh around
mid to late no no late mid to late 90s
is that every body that I had on the
show at the end of the show would say
something to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay at the end of the
interview
and I started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was
um I I had gone and done a show where I
was in a prison I was interviewing a
father who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even Behind Bars he said to me
is that okay how'd I do
and Barack Obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and George Bush
said it Beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to twerk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill dude yes
it's a working thing
sitting in that chair for 25 years
at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or I get to interview
you whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships every person that you
encounter every experience the person
wants to know
was that okay
and what I started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me and did what I say mean
anything to you and so I started to
listen with that in mind with that
intention of validating that your being
here you're speaking to me you're taking
the time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did I say anything that mattered every
single day
I would have a pre-show meeting
and have the producers come in and state
to me what is your intention
how do we want to use whoever is on this
show
whatever is happening on this show to
serve the audience in a way that
fulfills the mission of uplifting
enlightening encouraging as well as
entertaining and if it doesn't do that
then I can't do it I can't put my name
on it I figured this out early on in the
show I had read this quote from Dr King
uh one of my favorite quotes from him
that says not everybody can be famous
but everybody could be great because
greatness is determined by service and I
literally shifted I used that quote to
help me shift the way I saw the platform
of Television instead of like oh I'm on
TV how do I use that platform as a
platform of service is amen this was
what I did yeah yeah we know and you did
that pretty well too
but when you think about
growing and being empowered yourself it
is what you've been able to do for other
people
that that leaves you the fullest yes
most embarrassing oh my God
my most embarrassing moment was when the
um I told this on The Tonight Show one
so you've heard it or you didn't hear it
on The Tonight Show you missed Jay that
night my most embarrassing night when
the what was that the world soccer cup
thing came here Dean World Cup soccer
opened here in nineteen
was that 94 94.
because you guys were shooting it okay
World Cup soccer I am asked to introduce
I am the MC for the World Cup soccer
okay and I am coming out and I'd
rehearse the day before and I'd said to
them you guys have this plastic covering
the stage that is the same color as the
stage so you guys really need to change
that they did not so
the next day I'm on stage and I'm
introducing Diana Ross who's coming
across the other end of the field ladies
and gentlemen Diana Ross and Diana
starts I'm coming out and so she's
coming across the field I turned to walk
off the stage and fell in a hole the
hole that was covered with the plastic I
went straight through the plastic
oh fell scarred up my legs was bleeding
and couldn't get out but I could still
hear Diana singing
[Applause]
the security guy's going get her out get
her up
so four guys they pick me up like this
spread eagle and Carry Me Out of the
hall out of the hall I'm bleeding I go
to the other side they bandage my legs
and I limp back up
foreign
there's a bigger dream waiting for you
just waiting for you to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time wanting to be in somebody else's
life
and you don't get honored you don't get
revered you don't get celebrating
wanting what somebody else has
because
that which created you divine
intelligence to dreamed you from before
your ancestors ever knew they would
become your ancestors that which dream
the seed of you want you to know how
special how wondrous how mysterious how
complex how glorious how phenomenal you
are
and you get no credit messing in
somebody else's territory
or trying to have power over something
you have no control another one of my
favorite teachings is The Wizard of Oz
when the Wicked Witch of the West says
go away from here because you don't have
any power here you have no power in any
territory other than your own
oh but you are the master of that you
get to be the master of your own fate
you get to be the captain of your own
soul and if you just manage that
if you just took care of your territory
oh the Glorious glorious glorious
wondrous wondrous opportunities and
possibilities that are waiting for you
so the question is what are you
resisting
what are you pushing against what are
you not allowing what are you blocking
because you have this idea of who and
what you're supposed to be instead of
Leaning into the dream that's already
been created and waiting for you it's
waiting for you and those second I mean
it doesn't it's an instant thing it's a
shift in the way you see yourself and
the power from which you have come and
this is the thing I think I have to just
say everybody is feeding yourself on the
hysteria and the negativity you've got
to stay in the light but one of the
reasons why I was so excited is about a
wrinkle in time because the message is
that the darkness is spreading so fast
these days you must become a warrior of
the light and the reason that's so
meaningful to me is because that's how
I've LED my whole life and every moment
in that film I just felt like I'm just
saying what I normally say it's true and
and for these times the darkness is
there to show you your light look at
what has happened so if you put the
focus on look at what happened with the
darkness that showed up in Parkland and
the Darkness that showed up on the
streets of Ferguson and the Darkness
that showed up in many many many many
many many homes in Chicago with
shootings and uh senseless murders it
brings out the best in people it brings
out the best and so that's what it's
there we live on a planet where there is
Darkness and Light I teach them that
there is no life without cultivating a
spiritual life because you are first and
foremost a spiritual being having a
human experience
and if you lose sight of that it's easy
to get lost in the world and no one can
save a world that they're lost in when
they've lost sight of their own North
Star
so having a spiritual life actually
means actively and ritually creating the
space in your life all the time for
gratitude for kindness for empathy for
inspiration for joy and for reverence
for life in the home of your soul first
and then working to spread that inner
Joy outward it means
slowing down it means taking in the
moment it means being exactly where you
are not distracted somewhere else it
means knowing who you are and getting
about the business of fulfilling why you
really came to our planet I started
feeling like I think everybody knows I
I've moved my whole life on Instinct you
know I feel like now it's time to let
the show go I feel like it's time to
move on because I've grown as much as I
can grow when I've grown as much as I
can grow into space that's my instinct
to move I went through some tough times
after after I left the Oprah show I made
a conscious decision
that I did not want to be sitting on TV
with the Oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
I made a conscious decision decision
that when I felt I had said all that I
could say
and the audience had heard it that I
would move on and that I would not spend
my life regretting or trying to hold on
to what used to be or hold on to what I
had so I dreamed this dream
of starting a network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle it was a struggle because
I didn't I honestly goodness I did not
know what I was doing
I was trying to figure it out
I was trying to figure it out I thought
that the Oprah show audience would
follow us to own and then I realized
y'all didn't have cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so so it took me a minute and unlike
most people who you get to have your
mistakes in private some don't go right
in your life you get to talk about it in
private if I make a mistake it's on the
CNN crawl
or the CNN news so when I was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners I see churro Action Jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're going to stand
with you we're going to stand by you
thank you Roland Martin there were so
many people who said listen we believe
that this can happen
so I Dreamed a Dream
along with Tyler Perry who was my friend
who came to me and said Tyler
[Applause]
said I'm going to help you out because
Tyler can go home and write a script and
direct it produce it and
shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
Hollywood so we started with the
foundation of Have and Have Nots
[Applause]
If Loving You Is Wrong
love thy Endeavor Mama Hattie
and then I started to dream another
dream about scripted television because
in the beginning I was told you couldn't
do it you couldn't do it didn't have
enough money to do it
and I Dreamed a Dream
I read Proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trusted in their riches will fall
but the righteous will rise and Thrive
like a green leaf it is your job to make
yourself whole
not perfect but whole
and full
your world work in life your real work
is to fill yourself till your cup
runneth over
so that you're never grasping and needy
clamoring and insecure
but you can live your life assured and
your worthiness and your right to be
here and to become the best version of
yourself as a woman being you came from
very modest circumstances you didn't
come from a wealthy family well modest
is not the word well I was trying to be
polite I was I was actually poor and I
would you know a lot of the girls at my
school actually all the girls from my
school are poor and I was saying to them
just recently I was just in South Africa
for a graduation you know you all are
come come from the same circumstances
you were poor and one of the girls
raised their hand and said I don't like
using that word I go well if you're not
poor then you should excuse yourself
because that's why I'm paying for you
because
the choices were so
probably earlier in my life or career
the word would have bothered me but it
truly it was it was I was poor no
running water David or electricity
living with an outhouse
okay that's poor you can't get what you
want by focusing on what you don't want
this is about the need to establish as
many meaningful connections as we can if
we're going to save the world we have to
find a way to connect to each other to
connect to the nature that we're killing
to animals to history to an
acknowledgment of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism we need to connect
to the people we love and mean something
to us and more than that to the people
who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means we if we're going to continue
to survive and thrive on this planet
have to find ways to transcend the
politics of division and embrace the
places that Bond us where we find our
human ground everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams there
is there was a time
where I used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
course it's easy for me to say oh things
don't Define you because I got a lot of
things things is nice I like them
but this is what I learned when you can
surrender to the dream you get to live
in the space of the higher power
you get to live in the space that you
purposefully have come to Earth to claim
for yourself so
around 1980
four
I was sitting in bed one morning
uh Sunday morning should have been in
church but I wouldn't
I was reading the New York Times review
of The Color Purple
and I thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book I got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes and went to
the store to get the copy of the color
purple
I read The Color Purple in one afternoon
got went back to the bookstore bought
every book of The Color Purple I took
the books to the office and I said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my God you got to read this book color
purple I needed a book club I didn't
have one uh
so I pass out the book to everybody I
knew please read The Color Purple read
The Color Purple
then I start to hear that somebody's
going to do a movie about The Color
Purple but I don't know anybody in the
movie business by this time I was on AM
Chicago I don't know anybody I start
praying to God God please help me find a
way to get into Color Purple
I say Jesus I don't even have to have a
speaking part I will be because I went
to the movies and I saw on the movie
credits at the last credit there's
something called best boy
so I said Jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'd be all right by me I can be best
girl
I can carry the script I can help the
people with the water I can do whatever
so I start praying for the color purple
as as Divine Law would have it Quincy
Jones
comes to Chicago
and he is in Chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against Michael Jackson claiming that
Billie Jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so Quincy had taken the red eye to
Chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower and the
television in his hotel room is on AM
Chicago there sits
little chubby me
with my Jerry curl
on AM Chicago
Quincy Jones tells Reuben Cannon the
casting agent I think I found Sophia so
I get a call
for moving Cannon who says I'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition and I
say I have not been praying for moon
song
no
I've not been playing for moon song I've
been praying for The Color Purple he
said well I think you should come and
and audition so I go to audition you
know movie people ain't making
everything all secrets Steven Spielberg
didn't want anybody to know he was doing
Color Purple so on the outside of the
script it says moon song but I know all
the words by heart
so when I opened the script I know this
is The Color Purple Jesus this is the
color purple
yes
so I auditioned for The Color Purple I
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do I
want a part in the movie oh that I'm
thinking prayer prayer works
[Music]
prayer works
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
I auditioned in February March April May
comes I haven't heard anything so I call
Reuben Cannon
I say Mr Cannon
I'm sorry sir I haven't heard anything I
expected to hear something by now and
Reuben Cannon
African-American man
says to me
you don't call me
I call you
and I didn't call you
do you understand that I have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part real actresses and he tells me who
just left his office and I went well
okay I'm not getting that parked
so I hang up the phone and I start
crying I can't believe that God has
played this trick on me I think this is
a trick
so I decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fact has finally caught up with me
and now I must get rid of the fat in two
weeks
I am going to go to a fat Farm
and I'm going to lose 25 pounds
I'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
I'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so I I I also was trying to make peace
with it I said God I don't understand
I thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with God
I I thought it was for me I thought it
was for me
God you let me audition with somebody
named Harpo
that's my name backwards Jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months passed and then
then Reuben Cannon says real actresses
have just left his office
so I start to pray on the track I'm out
on the track at the Fat Farm
and I am running around at the track at
the Fat Farm it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but I don't even care because I am
praying to God to help me to Let It Go
help me let it go because now I've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life I start praying
running around the track
and I keep hearing this noise and I I
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and I'm running around the track
and I look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the track so then I
really start to cry
oh Lord help me help me let it go help
me let it go help me Let It Go God help
me Let It Go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say Okay Lord okay I'm gonna let it go
then you get up and you go well I think
I still got a little bit of it
I did help me Let It Go but I am not
going to be able to see the other
actress in my part I won't be able to
see it I won't be able to see color
purple just can't never see it the rest
of my life I won't be able to see it
so then I started
I don't know where it came from
I surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
I surrender all I sang and I cried I
sang and I cried and I prayed some more
until I could reach the point where not
only
not only will I be able to go to the
movie but I can bless the other actress
I can bless her
I can say
[Music]
I bless you I bless you I bless you with
this I surrender all
I surrender all
to thee my
blessed savior
I surrender all
and I tell you in my greatest testimony
that the instant I laid that thing down
[Music]
I'm telling you when I laid it down
when I laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore I
didn't feel anything about it anymore
when I let it go
when I intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than I could
ever know the instant that happened a
woman comes running out of the cafeteria
screaming all free
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody could pronounce my
name
I said yeah she said Somebody's on the
telephone for you he say named Spielberg
I get to the phone
he says I hear you're at a fat Farm
I said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says I'd like to see you in my office
in California tomorrow this was in
Wisconsin I was I'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
thank you
[Applause]
no problem do I have
I'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey I packed my bags
and I stopped at the Dairy Queen
[Applause]
I got three scoops just in case I'd lost
half a pound
and the next day I was in Steven
Spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired Oprah I'm dying to
know what is in your purse
thank you
I'm not quite sure myself
okay so somebody's gonna bring out my
purse
[Applause]
[Music]
this is this is Kelly herleman who
dresses me every day so this is this
this is uh
[Applause]
who did who did a real good job today
except I said to her I think these boots
are size nine and I wear a size ten
but I look cute but damn my feet hurt
okay
okay no no Kelly just stand here I don't
know this is the bag I was carrying this
morning it was right where'd you find
this
oh boy upstairs in the closet on the
table on the table okay this is what's
in my purse right now
[Applause]
um okay so there's my little makeup bag
okay it's cute all in one bag this was
given to me by Nate Burkes uh then
there's the and there's my there's my
wallet
there's my um
BlackBerry
it's the color purple uh y'all should go
see that I saw that the other night
[Applause]
now these are the sunglasses Ellen got
carry black pair and a brown pair
because you never know what you're going
to be wearing
this is a contact lens cleaning fluid
this is uh
charger for my Blackberry uh this is uh
movie Freedom land
this is a uh oh this is great this is a
poem my Angela just is going to do at
the White House and uh okay what is this
oh this is uh this is uh this is Maya
Angelou's itinerary so I know where she
is and uh that's about it okay what I
would like to know is oh got some pins
down here and some glasses reading
glasses and I got um
Sophie's balls just whenever we're
playing she only likes the clear ones
and uh that's it okay let's see how much
money do I have in my wallet
it got received I keep those for you
when I was shopping
and again this is how much I got a lot
all my money here we go
yeah I have a wallet
I have South African Rands ran and hold
on
two dollars
it's bad
amen oh no there's more there's more
money okay there's more there's more
money there's ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen dollars
it doesn't matter how far you might rise
at some point you are bound to stumble
because if you're constantly doing what
we do raising the bar if you are
constantly pushing yourself higher
higher the law of averages not to
mention in the myth of Icarus uh
predicts that you will at some point
fall
and when you do I want you to know this
remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just life trying to move us
in another Direction now when you're
down there in a hole it looks like
failure
so this past year I had to spoon feed
those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel bad for a little while give
yourself time to mourn what you think
you may have lost
but then here's the key learn from every
mistake because every experience
encounter and particularly your mistakes
are there to teach you and force you
into being more of who you are the
greatest lesson I've learned throughout
my career came from Maya Angelou
actually when I was you know first
meeting her and uh
after I'd known her for a while she said
baby you know
you need to know that when people show
you who they are
you believe them
the first time oh you know that lesson
too now first time and uh your problem
is it takes you 29 times to see the same
lesson coming in a different skirt
wearing a different pair of pants so I
think that has been one of my greatest
wisdom teachings is to assess uh from
people's behavior their actions not just
towards me but towards other people uh
who they are and how they behave because
if people talk about other people
they'll talk about you so I think in
business and in personal relationships
that's also been my greatest lesson the
challenge of life
I have found is to build a resume that
doesn't simply tell a story about what
you want to be but it's a story about
who you want to be it's a resume that
doesn't just tell a story about what you
want to accomplish but why a story
that's not just a collection of titles
and and positions but a story that's
really about your purpose because when
you inevitably stumble and find yourself
stuck in a hole that is the story that
will get you out
what is your true calling what is your
Dharma what is your purpose the way to
make movies is to do stuff that you love
because you know for 25 years I worked
on the Oprah show and uh stemming will
tell you that there were date nights
that I came home and I almost you know
it's hard to even like take off my
clothes because I knew I was going to be
getting up four hours later but I never
really felt exhausted like I never felt
exhausted but I never felt depleted so
do the work that comes straight from the
soul of you from your background from
stories that you've grown up with from
stories that bring you passion from
stories that you uh not just yearn to
tell but that if you don't tell them
they won't get told and when you when
you are operating you know the single
the single greatest uh wisdom I think
I've ever received other than when
people show you who they are is that the
key to fulfillment success happiness
contentment in life is when you align
your personality with what your soul
actually came to do I believe everybody
has a soul and has you know their own
personal spiritual energy so when you
can use your personality to serve
whatever that thing is you can't help
but be successful so if you do films
that come from the interior of your soul
you do work you do art that comes from
the interior of you it you cannot miss
it's only when you're doing stuff that
you think might make money you think it
may be a a hit or you think it may uh
bring you some level of attention or
success that isn't what does it I would
have to say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment have come
from working from the interior of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it it actually is so when you do
that you'll win there comes a point
and I'm really I'm really good at this
is at not holding on to what was and
being able to live in this present
moment you know I never was one of those
women who's afraid to tell your age or
you're trying to be something you're not
I mean I think for everything there's a
time and a season uh the Bible
completely right about that I think I
think
um and you know in your own self when
it's time to move from that my
television career began unexpectedly
uh as you heard this morning I was in
the Miss fire prevention contest
that was when I was 16 years old in
Nashville Tennessee and you had the
requirement of having to have red hair
in order to win up until the year that I
entered so they were doing the question
and answer period because I knew I
wasn't going to win in the swimsuit
competition so during the question and
answer period the question came why
young lady what would you like to be
when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so I had seen Barbara Walters on The
Today Show that morning so I answered
I would like to be a journalist
I would like to tell other people's
stories in a way that makes a difference
in their lives and the world and as
those words were coming out of my mouth
I went whoa this is pretty good
I would like to be a journalist I want
to make a difference well I was on
television by the time I was 19 years
old and in 1986 I launched my own
television show with a Relentless
determination to succeed at first I was
nervous about the competition and then I
became my own competition raising the
bar every year pushing pushing pushing
myself as hard as I knew sound familiar
to anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top and
we stayed there for 25 years
[Applause]
the Oprah Winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and I have to
tell you I became pretty comfortable
with that level of success we have to
make the choice every single day to
channel our own inner juicindas
to exemplify the truth and the respect
and the grace that we actually wish for
the world
we need to tell it as we're doing at
this conference we need to write it we
need to sing it we need to Proclaim it
we need to be it we need to be the truth
we have to be the respect we have to be
the fierceness the love that we want to
see and when we do that mark my words A
change is already coming I wake up in
the morning what you do and the first
thing I say is thank you that's my first
thing even before I'm awake even before
my eyes are really fully open I I say
thank you I can feel the Gratitude like
oh I'm still here I'm in a body thank
you so much I thank you for that and
then I go through the letting the dogs
out the whole you know brushing your
teeth and all that stuff and then I have
either silence or prayer or something
that acknowledges that I'm still here I
do not reach for that phone first that's
your problem that's your problem you
have no idea the power
of
noticing another human being and what it
feels like when somebody knows that they
have been seen truly seen by you it is
the greatest offering you can give and
all those years of the Oprah show the
greatest lesson I learned was that you
know after every show uh someone would
say invariably in one way or another
um how was that I'd finished an
interview with father who killed his
twin daughters I'd finish an interview
with politician Barack Obama Joe Biden
George Bush that Beyonce they all say
the same thing
how is that and so I started to see that
there's this common thread in our
Humanity where everybody wants to know
how was that
did I do okay did you hear me and did
what I say mean something to you
so I would have to say that recognizing
that in other people has helped me to
become you know a person of compassion a
person of understanding a person who can
interview anybody about anything because
I know that it's the core of you is the
same as core me you just want to be
heard okay let me ask all this have you
ever made a complete fool of yourself
over a celebrity
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I have I've never shared this story with
you but today I feel I have to let it
out it was 1973 or four I was uh 19 or
20. I can't quite remember but I was
working in Nashville and I had this
Obsession I mean obsession with Neil
Diamond
[Applause]
yeah
I would wake up
I would wake up in the morning playing
song song Blue everybody and I would go
to bed to crackle and Rosie and which is
not an easy thing to do in high school
because I could have lost my negro
membership card
you know there were not a lot of negroes
singing crackling Rosie but okay so I'm
working in television as this television
station and there was some kind of
benefit and Neil Diamond was there
because he was performing in town and so
I'm in the green room and I am by the
time 1973 I'm already uh anchor woman on
TV and so I walk into the green room and
there he is and so I say Mr Diamond
would you like some shrimp
[Applause]
I mean he says
and he says yes yes I'll take a show and
he took a shrimp and I'm like okay
and then he moved across the room and
then I followed him across the room
that's a big mistake that's the big
mistake people make so I follow him
across the room and so I'm like would
you like another shrimp
and he said yeah I'll take I'll take a
shrimp he did and then I followed him
again
so I'm just staring at him across the
room and finally I walked up and he goes
enough already
enough already okay so that was my
real diamond moment I know you all
understand better than most that real
progress requires authentic
an authentic way of being honesty and
above all empathy
I have to say that the single most
important lesson I learned in 25 years
talking every single day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our Human Experience
most of us
I tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
I found in every single interview is we
want to be validated
we want to be understood I've done over
000 interviews in my career
and as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to be and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
I heard it from President Bush
I heard it from President Obama
I've heard it from Heroes and from
Housewives I've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes I even heard
it from Beyonce and all of her Beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says what's
friends and family yours enemies
strangers and every argument in every
encounter every exchange I will tell you
they all want to know one thing was that
okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what I say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where Facebook was born
My Hope Is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and help make sure that the speed and
distance and anonymity of our world
doesn't cause us to lose our ability to
stand in somebody else's shoes and
recognize all that we share as a people
this is imperative for you as an
individual and for our success as a
nation what about something that you
feel like you've personally achieved or
overcome is there something that you are
especially proud of yourself for yeah
I'm especially proud of myself for not
uh living in the world of comparisons
you know uh years ago when I pulled out
that wagon of fat I was actually
comparing myself to everybody else or
what I thought you're supposed to look
like or what size you're supposed to be
so I'm now reached the point where I'm
really okay exactly where I am and
that's you know it's taken me a lifetime
practically to figure that out and being
okay exactly where you are because
preparing is a danger it's so hard
because we are in the world of insta
comparison you know and so the real
spiritual practice is to like Live From
Within and not let the world Divine who
you are but you do that for yourself
that's that's the hardest work you um
are now the CEO of your company you're
the owner and the CEO and you've got
thousands of people working for you yeah
and as a CEO do you have to say no to
people all the time and is that hard to
do uh you get other people who say no
that no okay
um saying no is hard that is one of the
big big lessons life lessons for me I I
grew up obviously girl uh raised in the
South women need to please wanting to
please everybody so it took me a long
time to get that lesson of only saying
yes to what you intend to say yes to and
and so I tried to do all of my business
decisions and personal decisions based
upon my intention many of you as I have
been as I am are where you are in your
life based upon what you believe and
it's not just what you think you believe
on the surface it's also your Shadow
beliefs that are holding you back from
moving into the life that you believe
you deserve what I know is if you're not
looking at the Shadows if you're not
looking at what is subconsciously
running through the tape in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough which is
a tape that's playing for a lot of
people
if you're not conscious of that then you
end up acting out of that belief system
and not out of what you know to be the
truest or want to be the truest for
yourself but you don't become what you
want because so much of wanting is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why Jim Carrey's story is so
powerful because he started to act as
though he already had it he would go up
to Mulholland Drive he would drive away
saying thinking I already have those
things I just haven't accessed them as
yet I believe those things are going to
come to me and I'm going to act like
they are so I'm going to move forward in
my life in order to draw that to myself
in such a way that my actions are in
alignment with what I say I believe so
if you start to think about that really
why are you where you are in your life
the choices that you have made have been
because of what you believe to be true
for yourself biggest transformation for
me was living my life with intention you
know what I know I live by this law of
that's the third law of motion physics
which you put out is coming back but
before you even put it out you have an
intention and so to have a Clarity of
intention about what you actually want
to do and why you want to do it is the
most important thing and then to just
set that vision and have every step you
make move you in the direction of that
Vision it doesn't mean that every day
it's going to happen some days you're
off track like I intended to work out 45
minutes I only got in 37 this morning
well that's better than two it's better
than zero and that's that's that's
that's what I said okay at least you got
some movement in and I'll go back and
I'll make up the other eight later but I
thought you just made it up actually as
I was walking I think I think this is
going to be eight minutes I'm gonna make
it up so uh it's it's about it's daily
renewal it's not one big gigantic goal
it's every day coming back giving
yourself the opportunity to get it right
because that's what every Sunrise means
oh gosh it's another chance to get it
right there has to be some way
that this Darkness can be Banished with
light
says the man whose little boy
was massacred on just an ordinary Friday
in December
so whether you call it
Soul or Spirit or higher self
intelligence
there is I know this there is a light
inside each of you all of us that
illuminates your very human beingness if
you let it and as a young girl from
rural Mississippi I learned long ago
that being myself was much easier than
pretending to be Barbara Walters
although when I first started because I
had Barbara in my head I would try to
sit like Barbara talk like Barbara move
like Barbara and then one night I was on
the news reading the news and I called
Canada Kanata and uh
that was the end of me being Barbara I
cracked myself up on TV
couldn't stop laughing and my real
personality came through and I figured
out oh gee I can be a much better Oprah
than I could be a pretend Barbara I have
a very big life
and so people with big lives can do big
things and so I started to think about
what was the best Christmas I ever had
in my life I grew up poor
my word for this year's purpose because
when I look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in
the year because your life's so full
yeah so another now I just go back and I
look through my phone so I was doing
that on New Year's Eve looking through
the phone at all the pictures all the
stuff we've done and I did a lot of
things but I didn't do a lot of things
on purpose with intentional purpose so
my thing this year is don't do anything
unless you have an intention and a
purpose behind it you wish yourself they
call her auntie Gail and Me Mama I said
you all wish to have a friend like
Auntie Gail you want to have a friend
who wants the most the best and the
highest for you I have never seen a
person like Gail I've never
yeah
you know everybody especially if you uh
are on the rise in your career and you
have had certain friends and they all
act like they're happy for you but not
everybody's happy for you and every now
and then you can hear just the teen
Nancy bit of jealousy you can hear it
you can sense it I've never had a
moment's jealousy from Gail in you know
the 30 odd years of her friendship
except for the one time
I was on stage dancing with Tina Turner
there were many days that I sat in my
chair across from one or two or five or
six or seven people and I would be so
frustrated because
I just wanted to shake people sometimes
and say why
didn't you pay attention to your life
I said on the show probably the
producers tell me that they counted 33
times but I know I thought it at least a
thousand times I would say listening to
your life
as it Whispers to you first so that it
does not have to knock you upside the
head with a brick or come crashing down
on you as a brick wall is one of the
greatest principles of life because
there are many things that happen in
life that are beyond our control natural
disasters death
unexplained events but there are also
many many things in life which we can
control and become out of control
because you're just not paying attention
you are sleepwalking through your life
and I have seen this so many times on
the show I wanted to take the guess and
go would you just be your attention so
this is what I've learned and how I've
explained it to myself
life Whispers to you all the time your
life is speaking to you all around from
the time you wake up in the morning and
every single experience that's coming
into your personal space into your
physical space all of those experiences
are speaking to you they're telling you
something about your life and about your
circumstances it
you don't get the whisper The Whisper
gets louder
if you don't get the whisper when it
gets louder it gets I call it like a
little Pebble like a little thump upside
your head when I was a kid if I was
doing something my grandmother didn't
like she just turned around and thump me
she wouldn't even look at me she just
give me a thump and I know that's that's
my cue to stop it or you we're gonna get
worse
The Whisper is the message the pebble or
the thump upside the head usually it's
gone into a problem you don't pay
attention to the problem the problem
becomes a brick upside your head the
brick upside your head is a crisis you
don't pay attention to the brick upside
your head the crisis turns into a
disaster and the whole house brick wall
comes falling down now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day I want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not
unless to get motivated believe Nation
we're here
we're here to
take her when you commit to a plan of
action of when and how you're going to
follow through when you write it down
you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you commit publicly to
somebody else it jumps to 95 chance from
30 something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe Nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and I'm going to
show on screen sometime next week to
celebrate
when did you realize in Chicago or
Baltimore that you actually had a skill
as an interviewer that was really better
than anybody else's and where do you
think that skill came from I never
thought it was better than anybody
else's what I do think I have that is
really uniquely my own is my ability to
connect to the audience because my skill
comes not from my interviewing ability
my skill comes from my listening ability
and my skill comes from me knowing
fundamentally
inside myself that I am no different
than the audience so what gave me the
power in the seat and the power with the
microphone was I always saw myself as
the surrogate for the audience so I
would ask people questions that I would
not normally ask I mean I asked some
really embarrassing embarrassing
question once not because I wanted to
know the answer
but because I thought the audience did
and then I thought I'm not going to ask
what doll I just wants the next time and
when I get in that situation it was a it
was a I put myself in a bad situation I
asked Sally Field when she was dating
Burt Reynolds I asked remember this Gail
I asked Sally Field
did Bert sleep with his toupee on
was the answer or the question
and I would never do that today I
wouldn't do it because I was doing it
because I was getting pushed by The
Producers like people want to know
people want to know so I was thinking I
was doing it on behalf of the audience
she shut down
and I could see that it embarrassed her
and I never got another thing from her
so I thought okay that was wrong I
learned from that if you want more top
10 videos they're not on this channel
anymore I have a dedicated Channel just
for it go check it out the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you then